the heat is sweltering out in the field
there's a little shelter from the
burning sun peter angelo and his wife
are book magic diligently harvest their
crop by hand each and every grain is
important this field is their main
source of income we've hardly had any
rain this year and therefore the harvest
has failed badly there's simply not
enough crop and some of it is rotten
without support we don't have enough to
eat
look a coach works for the German aid
organization Ville Tonga hill fir he
regularly comes to a while west to check
on the living conditions for local
residents mostly it's bad news like
Peter in a book many here have lost
their crops and what I've seen inside is
not enough this will take a family of
seven people from now up to every and
thereafter there will be they will they
will do there will not be having any
food in the store again so they will be
studying hunting for other means of
trout to get food which is very
difficult here because the prices for
food commodities is very high and beside
the unavailable in the market many
products used to come from neighboring
Kenya and Uganda but since the start of
the civil war the supply roads have
closed with no food on sale at the local
market is all but deserted a few items
here are more like treasures on display
in a museum it's food that Peter in a
book can no longer afford and as if the
drought wasn't enough residents say the
security situation in the war-torn
country makes finding supplies even more
difficult
yeah yeah I guess I used to go to the
forest everyday to gather firewood and
edible roots but it's no longer safe
here I can't go to the market anymore to
buy firewood here too we are affected by
the conflict in July we were attacked by
rebel forces they stole cows and goats
and took some of our other possessions
they caused chaos then they disappeared
back into the bush but we are afraid
that they're still out there the
situation in South Sudan is dire a
seemingly endless civil war and a threat
of famine the world's youngest country
faces a difficult future